hello everyone my name is mashtavo
hussaini i'm a phd candidate at the paul
marajas school of business at university
of california irvine
um this is a joint work with
vijay vasirani
titled nash bargaining based models for
matching markets
one-sided and two-sided fisher and ro
debaru
so i will start with an overview of
matching based market design and the
nash bargaining game
in general
then we will
see
some connections and comparison between
um highlands egg hauser scheme and nash
bargaining base models
um i will
talk about our proposed one-sided and
two-sided nash bargaining based models
followed by two solutions and methods
for solving these problems and finally i
will conclude
my talk with some computational
experiments
so matching based markets are uh
different from the usual commodity based
markets
in the sense that
they are not necessarily driven by price
and
these are matching markets because
neither side can simply choose but also
needs to be chosen
um so classical examples of
matching markets are
for example matching students to schools
or residents to hospitals and so on
but uh recently with the recent
innovative matching markets such as
adwords uber and airbnb
these applications
have led
to a major revival of the area of
matching based market design
but a general issue uh in this area is a
lack of
models that can use
cardinal utilities
um to address this issue we propose nash
bargaining based matching market models
um so assume that we have an agents and
and indivisible goods
where each agent eye has one dollar to
spend and has a utility uij
for good j
um
so the prominent solution based on
cardinal utilities is the highlands egg
hauser scheme
which creates a parity between
supply and demand using a pricing
mechanism
to use the pricing mechanism
hc assumes that goods are
divisible uh by assuming that there is
one unit of um
probability share of which good
then hc finds a fraction of perfect
matching of goods and agents as well as
a price for these
goods
to find equilibrium
hc enjoys some nice game theoretical
properties for example
it satisfies pareto optimality and envy
freeness uh as well as uh incentive
company compatibility in the large but a
major drawback
of this scheme is its lack of
computational efficiency
which
then makes these nice properties
of limited applicability
um
an in-person mesh parking in game um
consists of a pair
n and c
where n is
called
the feasible set is a compact and convex
sets and its elements are vectors whose
components are utilities that
the and players can simultaneously
accrue there is also a vector c which is
called the disagreement point and its
components are utilities uh with which
the end players are crew
if they decide not to participate in the
proposed solution
we say
an instance nc is
feasible if there exists a point v such
that
the utility of agent i under v
is strictly better than their
disagreement point
so the solution to a feasible instance
um
is
the point v that satisfies the following
four axioms
the first axiom is pareto opticality
which means no point in and
weakly dominates v
and the second is symmetry which
in the sense that um
if we renumber the players on then a
corresponding
solution to the new instance would be
the one that we renumber the
coordinates of our solution v
uh also the third
axiom is invariance under a fine
transformation of utilities meaning that
if the utilities of any player is
transformed with some a fine
transformation then the solution
can be up to the new instance can be
obtained by the same transformation
finally the fourth axiom is independence
of irrelevant alternatives meaning that
if v is a solution to instance um
in c
and s is a
convex combin convex and compact subset
of n such that it contains both and this
argument point c and our solution v then
v is also a solution to this instance
s and c
using an
elegant proof uh
nash showed that if the game nc
is feasible then
there is a unique point in v
in n that satisfies these axioms
um also it turns out that this point is
the solution to this uh
maximization problem where we maximize
the product of the difference between
the utilities of the agents and their
disagreement points with respect to
b belonging to the feasible set
and we can in fact uh turn this problem
into
um this convex problem
and find the solution to the nash
bargaining game by installing this one
and since it is convex then it can be
com
solved efficiently
uh with a nash bargaining based models
we sacrifice some properties of
the highlands egg hauser scheme but we
gain um efficient solubility
obviously these nice properties of hc
have little meaning
without solvability
um
so with our approach
we yield a plethora of
matching market models these models
range from not only
one-sided but also to two-sided models
as well as fisher setting and aerodiver
setting
and
the utility functions range from linear
all the way to the ntf
okay
so
to see some connection between
highland
zig hauser scheme and nash bargaining
based mechanisms
we first pay attention to our shift from
pricing mechanism to a nash bargaining
mechanism
so we have proposed a shift from a
pricing mechanism to a dashboard
game-based mechanism for matching market
models and this shift arises two
questions
the first question is
is there
is either type of mechanism reducible to
the other
and the answer is no uh in fact um we
can easily verify that under
uh an affine transformation of the
utilities of agents
um as we just saw the nash bargaining
solution undergoes the same a fine
transformation
while an hc equilibrium remains
unchanged so they are not reducible to
each other
the second question is is this shift a
principled one
and the answer is yes in fact there's a
fundamental connection between these two
mechanisms through the linear fusion
unit demand problem or lfup this in this
problem um
we we are concerned with finding a
fraction or perfect matching between
agents and boots when agents have linear
utilities
so if we solve this problem using a
pricing mechanism we derive the hc
equilibrium and if we solve it using a
nash bargaining mechanism we derive one
lf which is our most basic
uh
nash bargaining based matching market
model and i will talk about it more
next
okay so uh we proposed several nash
bargaining based models uh categorized
on their one-sided and two-sided
matching markets
and under one-sided matching markets we
start with um
our most basic model which is uh one lf
and um
we have
linear fusion nash bargaining white side
matching
market we um we then
we will see
our next model which is a linear arrow
to peru a nice bargaining and one-sided
matching market model we then generalize
these models to non-linear
non-linear
utility functions namely
separable and non-separable piecewise
linear concave
one-sided
matching markets
for the two-sided uh we generalize are
one-sided to two-sided and we call it
2lf
which is
under the linear fisher setting but
we can easily extend this
setting to
the arrow the brew and
non-separable and separable and all
other utility functions
okay
so um
our linear fisher nash bargaining
one-sided matching market
or
one lf for short
is um our basic model and it's a
standard application is
in matching agents to goods
so here let's uh let's define some
notation and
x denotes the set of fraction on perfect
matchings and each agent's
i has a utility for good j denoted uij
and under
a given fraction of perfect matching the
utility of h and i would be the
summation
over all goods
um
this setting um is in fact identical to
the high landsat houser setting but the
difference uh is that uh the definition
of solution to an instance
is different between these two settings
and
we solve this problem using a nash
bargaining
mechanism
by
solving this
convex combination and convex program
given here
our next model is a linear aerodynamic
part in one-sided matching market
where
on top of what we had for
our fischer model we also have a
disagreement point c
which is not necessarily zero and
it
for example it may corresponds to an
initial endowments of the agents
we also assume that the instance is
feasible in the sense that there exists
an allocation
under which the corresponding utility of
each
agent is
strictly greater than her disagreement
point
and this model is applicable when agents
start with an initial endowment of goods
and then change them to improve their
happiness and we can cast it as this
convex program here note that
this disagreement point up here appears
in the objective function and if it sets
ci to zero then we
we get
our
1lf model
to generalize to
non-linear cases we first consider the
separable piecewise linear concave
utility functions which is uh analogous
to uh
our one lad model but
but with the difference that the h genes
have
separable precise linear concave
functions
f i j
each of these functions are represented
by some segments
each segment k
has lengths
l i j k
and the utility rate uijk uh which uh
agent i accrues um
utility per unit of good eye good jay
received when she is
uh which is getting an allocation
corresponding to this segment
with this definition the total unit
utility of y or i would be the simply
the summation or of these functions over
all goods
and we can cast this problem as this
convex
optimization problem note that
here our x variables have three indices
one for the agents one for the goods and
one for each segment for each pair of
agent and good
our second non-linear model is the
non-separable piecewise linear concave
utility
um abbreviated one
in led
and it differs from
our previous model in that agent's
utility functions are now assumed to be
non-separable
these utility functions are very general
and
can be used to for example capture
whether goods or compliments or
substitutes
and much more
so we can um
we can consider utilities of this form
and a special case is
the lean thief utilities under which
agents
[Music]
want some
goods
in specific in specific ratios
and
this model is
[Music]
suitable for modeling utilities and
goods are complements of each other
with this definition we we can
find the optimal solution by solving a
convex optimization of this form
it is natural to assume that
each side
has a utility function over the other
therefore we also consider a two-sided
uh version of our matching markets uh
the simplest
setting being linear fisher nash
bargaining two-sided matching market
in this setting our goal is to find a
perfect matching between agents and jobs
where both agents and jobs have linear
utility functions
in keeping with the axiom of symmetry
under national bargaining we posit that
the desires of agents and jobs are
equally important therefore our feasible
set is now in a two-n-dimensional space
where each utility vector v
consists of um
two n elements the first two and uh
elements uh correspond to the utilities
of the agents and the second to them and
the second elements correspond to the
utilities of jobs
and similar to our other models we can
cast this model
as a convex optimization problem of this
form
to solve these problems uh we present
two solution methods um
namely central cutting plane
algorithm
and frank wolf algorithm both of these
algorithms rely on linear approximations
of these problems and converts to the
optimal solution in polynomial time
but to
but to obtain fast implementations um
we need some
new ideas we understand our methods
where
we enhance these uh methods
tailored to our specific problems
and i will talk about these insane
as well
our first algorithm is the cutting plane
algorithm let's
say fv is the objective function of one
of these models for example let's say
it's the objective function in
one led
um
since
the objective functions are concave we
can show that
f is upper bounded by the hyperplanes at
each arbitrary
point we had using this relation we can
reformulate our optimization problems
as semi-infinite linear
programs of this form where eta is
replaced uh
replaces the objective function and is
uh
upper bounded by
these uh hyperplanes for each trial
solution we had
uh since it this
formulation contains infinitely many
constraints of this form
the natural way of solving it is to
replace this feasible set with a
manageable subset and let's call that
enhanced and then we iteratively grow
and had um
to
make this relaxation a tighter
relaxation
until the bounds of
this problem converge to the optimal
solution of the original problem
but a better way of solving this problem
is uh to
find the center of the hypograph
approximation instead of finding the
optimal corner point at each iteration
um
with the linear program of this form we
can obtain the radius sigma and the
center
of the largest ball that can be
inscribed in
in inside the hypergraph approximation
and we can show that as the algorithm
iterates the radius sigma diminishes and
it approaches zero while uh the center
of the hypograph approaches to our
optimal solution to the original problem
we also propose several enhancement
techniques for faster
convergence
the first enhancement is
[Music]
regarding cut generation
rather than cutting off the current
points
each iteration we propose to perform a
line search between the current solution
and the best solution identified so far
uh this may not only improve the bounds
but also we generate more effective cuts
because this intermediate point is more
likely to go into the interior of the
feasible region
um a common issue in cutting plane
algorithms in general is that um
lp solvers
may have
difficulties in um
in
handling the unbalanced cuts
and we call the
cut unbalanced if the coefficients of
the variables are very different in in
the cut we propose to replace our eta
which corresponds to the objective
function value with
[Music]
with
some
some scalar multiplied by a new variable
so that we can scale
this variable and thus
balance the cut
another issue is specific to this
problem is that our objective functions
involve logarithm
function therefore they cannot
be
they they cannot have an argument where
v
v minus c i is zero if it happens that
for some solution at some iterate of the
cutting plane if we the i minus ci is
zero
we cannot extract a cut from the
solution and um our proposed solution is
to instead of cutting this point we
find
[Music]
its closest point in the interior of the
feasible region by taking a convinced
combination of this point and some
arbitrary
integer point
um finally
we would like to be able to
use the information and during
iteration t
um and
we obtained during iteration t in the
subsequent iteration
um to do so we use dual simplex method
which um
which helps us avoid solving the lps
from a scratch at
g duration
the second
solution algorithm that
yeah this idea behind this method is
placed in nonlinear objective function f
with its linear approximation
trial solutions and in our case if we
replace f with its linear approximation
we
we obtain a maximum weight matching
problem therefore the solutions that we
find at each iteration are integral
perfect matchings
and then the algorithm continues by
doing
line search between this integral
perfect matching and
the trial allocation that we had to find
the next trial uh allocation
and since this uh
step involves solving a max weight
matching uh it can be
um it can be solved efficiently and
therefore the algorithm overall is
efficiently solvable
uh so
let's start
with
linear utility models
for
the computational experiments namely
our
one led one lf and 2nf
note that these models have similar
structures uh in the sense that their
feasible regions are all matching
polytopes therefore both frankfurt
algorithm and cutting plane can handle
them efficiently
we consider several scenarios here
um we consider two scenarios for the
utility mattresses one is where the
utility matrices are bi-valued we call
them binary and the other case is where
utilities are general integers so we
call them non-binary
we also
consider different number of agents
and goods
from 200 of all the way to 2000
i have discarded the smaller instances
because the running times are negligible
here
we have also
considered different parameters to
capture the sparsity of the utility
mattresses through this parameter row
so the smaller value for row means
the in sense is sparser
uh from these results we can observe
that frank wolf can handle the binary
cases uh consistently uh more
efficiently than
the
cutting plane algorithm
while
both frank wolf and cutting plane are
suitable for the non-binary case
with a cutting plane performing slightly
better
than
the frank wolf particularly in the
denser
cases
now with then
with the
non-linear utility functions um one sad
and one nad we have considered a
different
number of agents and different segments
for the utility functions
for the separable case
capital k denotes the number of segments
for each pair of agent and good and we
have considered two numbers and for the
non-severable case it captures the
number of uh
segments for each agent
as expected we can observe that as we
increase the number of segments the
problem becomes increasingly more
challenging but
the cutting plane algorithm
has managed to solve all the instances
in
a few minutes
but with
the non-separable case it turns out that
the problem is more challenging that
than the separable case
and um but the cutting plane algorithm
solves
all the large instances um up to optimal
um solution
in less than one hour and uh but it
it starts to struggle for
the cases where the number of segments
are
larger
so uh
with this i end my talk thank you for
your attention
and we would be happy to hear your
questions